all right Zach all right Zach uh where
are you from originally where'd you grow
up originally I'm from St Charles
Missouri near the St Louis region uh
I grew up pretty much in like white
Suburbia
like not much
do it like middle class not really upper
class not really lower
but uh you know I uh I always didn't
find myself towards the
lower parts of the neighborhood you know
even though I was in middle class or
whatever
why are you attracted to that
um I think because people are more
humble more honest you know they are
what they are you know it did people out
here like us like on skid World Report
people we are you know you see what we
are you know you know who they are
they're out there every day living it
you know no offense to upper class
people but you know Ted Bundy was a
[__] serial killer and he was a
lawyer and a political white guy you
know people hide stuff like that you
know I think people out here that are
poor naturally
humble because they gotta be honest they
don't really have no choice we're down
to earth more honestly no yeah what was
your family life
uh my family well my mom my dad were 16
17 when they had me
my dad got thrown out of Navy even
drinking my mom obviously a party or two
so by the time I was six months old I
was giving up for adoption by my to my
grandparents on my uh my dad's side
when I
basically because they couldn't take
care of me when I was you know younger
and uh you know my dad lived with my
grandpa until he was like 30s my mom in
a prison
like you know I stayed with them your
parents were into drugs oh yeah my dad
uh my dad just died actually just
recently the a year and a half ago now
from uh heart failure from meth well he
had bad cholesterol and all the other
stuff but like basically it was meth too
my mom was a hair my first heroin dealer
um like she's raging opiate addict I had
to go two feet across from the trail
back
come on let me get some heroin you know
what I'm saying like it's it's terrible
my bonding experience between my [__]
mom and dad were shooting up together
that's how we had Christmas
you know what kind of teenager were you
uh well we went with my pops you know
he's depressionary guy man you know 12
brothers and sisters you know he's
strictly old school you know what I'm
saying like I've only work ethic as him
you know what I'm saying like he uh you
know he was basically bread and butter
guy I go to work I put the food on the
table I comb all my sleep that's it
pretty much the man could rebuild the
car but couldn't run no [__] washer
and dryer it was insane to me
so like uh my grandma died when I was in
third grade so I could pretty much left
me pretty much Solitaire growing up uh
as a child um
like from probably 10 to
eight almost eighteen I didn't really
[__] you know have anyone upbringing
me my grandpa kind of was went recluse
my whole family left you know it was
just me and [__] my room with the
Super Nintendo and that's what kind of
was my best friend you know what I'm
saying a lot of my problems now because
of that and not having the social skills
and you know not getting out and
exercising stuff like that you know you
graduate huh you graduated high school
actually I didn't I I quit on purpose
actually with a credit to go
um I got drunk and uh I told my English
teacher who was only two years older
than me at the time when I was in that
school uh that she was a [__] English
teacher and couldn't teach Beowulf or
[__] and then she got mad at me and then
I recited it to her in [__] German
and she [__] threw me out and I said
[__] you guys I don't need you
my own [__] Pride got in the way
there of letting me finish up but I did
get my GED later on actually Ace did
first test then you have to take a
practice whatever and then I taught guys
in Job Corps which I
tutored it
to uh actually the inner city black
youth when did drugs start for you
when do drugs start
um
drugs well I started drinking with the
first thing I did was 16. with my
buddies in a football field and uh I
drank 16 beers in two and a half hours
and I was like I just from that on I
just I love the [__] dude I couldn't
have enough of it I could never drink
enough there was you know it was on
and uh that's basically started
everything you know I started smoking
weed you know and weed led to other [__]
you know like Coke or you know whatever
it didn't matter I was you know I I
trade anything like I'd have bag of
weeds oh you got a bag of pills cool
here I'll give you back a leave for it I
was the one stop Prescription Shop dude
I tried it all I was like gonna try
everything once you know
[__] I like the chemical change you
know like I tell people what what
chemical substance releases your
inability to [__] think
mine was alcohol
like I mean all drugs inhibit you at
some point but like that was what really
made me a bad person I think
and I haven't been drinking but like you
know then I dealt with speed for a long
time I mean but I was working 75 hours a
week doing speed you know I never I
never missed a day at work
so like you know it just it battling
back and forth and recently it just
mostly it's been my diabetes that's been
knocking me out the most
because I can't you can't really be
diabetic and homeless and also have a
drinking and Drug bomb it's like you
might as well just sign up for death you
know
and uh so I I just
I uh
I went on a rampage for a long time like
when I was
I guess
[Music]
20 23 I want to say after he was 23.
like I uh I should take off the cap yeah
yeah
yeah I don't do that much because uh
my head I've been hit a lot
um
you wanted a rampage
yeah like when I really started using
drugs like a lot of them in different
ones and stuff because uh
I just got out of Job Corps
and uh
I got my license as a pharmacy
technician actually
um and Job Corps only two and a half
years and uh
Practice Pharmacy then uh
I just decided that I didn't want to do
anymore because it's getting paid more
as a cook
and I could I could get high as a coach
I couldn't I couldn't smoke weed as a
[__] Farm Tech I they wouldn't let
you so I I was like [__] it I'll just
cook and uh
I just while I was just drinking all the
party drugs and everything happening at
my house
I started uh I started using
intravenously because I was diabetic
uh
and that's when it's like you know it
really that's why I was going to say
drugs took off when I started using
intravenously because it's a whole new
ball game
you know I'm not the best guy to get
high with you know I ain't give me your
[__] it's legal they can't do nothing to
me and I got script for it you know I
got free drugs every day for it just
[__] hang out and get high with them
you know like
and
it
got to the point to where I uh
just got tired of living and I just
I had my mom my own mom went on got me
enough hair when you killed myself she
knew she didn't she wouldn't even like
sit around for her she got it and left
out the door
and I I [__] OD'd the first time when
I was like 20 like 23.
and uh
uh I did it purposely and
I'll never forget the first the last
thing I said to my brother was
man it feels like [__] Disneyland I
smacked my face off the side of the
[__] TV and died right there in the
spot I was like Mike Tyson just waved my
sound dude I woke up you know and uh
I went after that experience happened to
me that's when I first tried to like get
my life on track uh I guess off drugs
alcohol and partying on that but uh
you know I never had uh
much guidance in that really you know uh
I never I never been in trouble really
either to make me have to get serious
like I've never been court ordered to
stop doing drugs I've never been uh you
know put in jail for longer than a
period of couple of two three days you
know I don't
I'm not saying that I shouldn't be but
you know I've always been able to even
squeeze down or just like you know make
sure I cover my tracks whatever you want
to call it I've gotten lucky
to where I uh I just
I don't know I just never had to do it I
guess no one's ever made me like or
showed me the way
so I just kept doing it
and uh
the past couple years actually the first
time I've actually gotten trying to get
sober
um I see some people's lives in the past
four years actually trying to get
somewhere like this and uh
uh
I I uh I can't uh seem to get it right
myself what are you using now huh what
are you using no right now
um I usually met mostly uh marijuana
honestly mess was my main thing there
for a second alcohol was was pretty bad
though when I first got here
ah
not bad I mean but I was having at least
a couple a day at least or more
and it really messes up my diabetes
I was a heroin act for two years
straight like it slammed here when I
quit that I mean after never drug in the
book but the thing I struggled with most
right now is probably a mess
and depression I mean like honestly
drugs
are probably one of the catalysts that
everybody's from but my main problem is
myself I [__] get depressed or I get
just whatever and I just don't care and
I'll binge juice
if the depression wasn't in place you
wouldn't have a drug problem
I think if I had more um
like therapeutic stuff yeah like more
mental uh stability as far as
you know going to
therapy class you know psychologists
stuff like that
and versus to where I've landed gotten
to this point where it's like you know
now I don't even want to really go
because
you know I get anxiety and then you know
it causes a whole ordeal
um
that's where I think that uh
the drugs helped me the most is whenever
I I open up more whenever I'm not
you know
sober it's it's easier for me uh
but yeah no I don't think I don't I
don't think if my depression was there
really that I'd have a drug problem
because when I wasn't depressed actually
when I'm the happiest I don't really I
smoke weed that's about it
and I don't really use other drugs like
honestly don't the last time I actually
used drugs like purposely not just
because they were there given to me or
like I really need to get drugs with
probably like a couple two three months
ago
I think I just was having a moment and I
just like I need to go use drugs usually
people just give them to me and [__] man
I'm just part of the [__] crew you
know I don't even have to ask I just
walk outside and you get drugs
I [__] told the doctor that this last
time dude when he was he wouldn't give
me any pain prescription because uh I
tested positive for uh math
and I was like look man I was like yeah
I did I do my whatever obviously it's
not opiates I'm not in here and begging
for it but I was like you know if I want
drugs dude I'll just walk outside I can
go get them faster from them and I get
them from you I was like dang at the
point I was like point is them in legit
pain so do you want me to go take a
chance take a hit and die are you gonna
give me a [__] that I know it's at least
in it
at least let me go to sleep
and the guy actually gave me drugs
he legit gave me morphine right after
that
man I I I've learned that it's just it's
not to me I don't care about the drugs
man honestly like they are the Catalyst
like I said of most problems but like if
I could just get it consistent
like
routine
and like a circle that I can trust
then I'm good but like that's my problem
with that [__] lost so many trust and
people betrayed me so many times and
it's like
trust nobody ask questions later you
know what's your angle
what are in the drugs you're using I
have to use the drugs because if I don't
then you think I'm a cop and I'm in a
fight
are you on the streets now huh are you
on the streets no um I'm at the Weingart
actually I've been there for the past
four and a half months yep how's it I'm
trying to get housing yeah I I had to
threaten to kill myself to get to this
point actually
um it's ridiculous I started in Diamond
Bar when I got here in Orange County
and I got to Skid Row they sent me here
on Christmas didn't even tell me about
it I was in what's called a recuperative
Care Center
um
for my homelessness and diabetes because
my diabetes is so bad
like I take four shots of insulin a day
I used to weigh 250 pounds
like yeah I was a big dude oh yeah I I
was you know I was really really really
out of shape a large portion of my life
and uh it affected me later the drugs
and the drinking actually I think the
drinking made my diabetes come fruition
drinking so much that I drink my
pancreas in the submission
and just like I lost half my body weight
you know people are like oh he's on
drugs I wasn't even doing drugs all the
time
I was just going to bathroom 14 times a
day
and I exhibit a lot of the same signs as
someone who's on drugs when you got
really bad diabetes symptoms
my sugar levels hit 636 when I went
yeah it's a normal person's is 85 to 125
right I was six times normal level
doctors like how are you gonna stand it
I was like I don't know man I just work
through it you know ate a couple band
pills and went on about my business
you know don't [__] about it it's my
apostate and found out that I had
neuropathy I couldn't feel my feet I
still got it and that's why I was like I
didn't know I was in pain
and uh it like it debilitated me and
that's what started my heroin addiction
with my neuropathy I was doing opiates
and [__] and I was like
it it ended up bad
but
um
I uh
I took
what was it I took 150 milligrams of
morphine
um and that's what the doctor told me
that I decided they figured out I had uh
what's it's called it's a I can feel
what it's called some kind of Billy
where you process drugs faster
the normal people from pain tolerance
but uh he gave me 150 milligrams of
morphine and I was it didn't affect me
for almost an hour and a half
they gave me an anesthesia with my
appendix burst I it was supposed to keep
me out for three and a half days I woke
up in two and a half hours
they were like this you shouldn't be up
so I I I chalk it up to just being being
a seasoned user but it's some kind of
condition where I synthesize them faster
I don't know what it is
but I think it's with the only thing
that's kept me alive my opiate addiction
I just get it out before it kills me I
mean I died last week
actually that's why I went to the
hospital
right out here that's why I didn't talk
to you
I was smoking some I smoked smoking some
speed with a guy and he uh diet speed I
didn't know what's in it
woke up out front
and scared the [__] out of me you know
like that's I think I think that's what
gets me now the most about being out
here using drugs the guys they don't
care it's not about business no more
you're just a number
there's another one to replace you
you're just a number now you just down
there's no loyalty there's no you know
there's you just you know the guy out
there I don't give a [__] what happens
here I'm saying like
I uh
I believe uh that one way or another
Skid Row will figure itself out but if
we don't band together soon then it's
gonna be bad for everyone
in the whole world
how was he me 35 35
yeah you have kids no kids to my
knowledge
you've been in love before huh you've
been in love before oh yeah yeah yeah
I've only had well I consider love and
relationships only real four serious
relationships in my life we make it past
six months that's serious
the mega pass a year we're factually
married
I've only been with four women longer
than a period of a year in my life
and four years as long as I ever made
four and a half
and uh both of them were messed up
relationships you know like
they were broken I'm broken you know
drug problems you know it's like
they both live in Las Vegas too which is
funny now you're the same area
and uh
it's uh
it's a weird game that I love I've been
in love
I said I think like twice for real real
and then I just gave up on it
it's just too hard I don't feel like
doing it anymore
too much invested time and then feelings
and
I'm just like
numb to it now I guess it also helps me
get off the street last time I was first
time I was I was homeless I went six
months without women
drinking swearing all that stuff
got off the street
and everything got myself John slept
behind there for two weeks
it was it was good it was in Vegas
I just
all hit the floor again once I get with
women
so
what I think is love is probably not the
right one
it's your biggest regret
nine biggest Grant I forget what I said
last time it was good
my biggest regret actually is
not seeing more of the world and
adventuring more so much of it I've only
seen so little of it you know just the
states I want to see more as much as I
can
you know
and
I guess you know
not living every moment I can to the
fullest
you know
because you know
for example last week it might be your
last day you never know
I [__] want to make sure that
whatever I was doing last time I'm good
with it you know
you know is that what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
that
no matter what happens out there
in this world
the world will go on with or without you
so the moment you think that you're so
significant or you're so important that
the world needs everything else it
really no one nothing really does it
will live without you we'll move on
so I think that everyone should just go
on with the world roll with the punches
you know
that's our problem we ever once be
individual we need to just roll with it
together
all right Zach thank you so much for
sharing your story hey you want wish you
lots of luck out here
thanks